[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
quel bonheur des autres quel bonheur de
retrouver maître moya avec qui on a
passé tous et quel ensemble
alors il fallait bien entendu on n'a pas
droit tellement de se parler parce que
c'est le huissier la gfa loi de savoir
qu'à dans les bois n'est pas en droit de
savoir qui a bien joué j'ai rien le
droit de savoir dans cette émission je
viens ils me disent tu fais ton travail
tu t'en vas et on veut plus te voir les
cherry a un gros problème
je reçois des des quolibets de la part
des cadreurs montre le comice fout de ma
gueule depuis tout à l'heure j'ai misé
j'ai mis des pompes de bernard de la
villardière vas-y botro les montrer aux
téléspectateurs
j'ai eu des chaussures de bernard de la
villardière à bars de mocassins al gore
je me suis fait charrier
non mais ils n'arrêtent pas de me
charrier depuis tout à l'heure à il ya
20 ans c'était kevin costner il ya dix
ans c'était brad pitt tout doucement
chez dessange et autres lucie sinclair
ont commencé à demander une hanouna
alors vous mettez du père le sort et la
douceur parce qu'avant il était un petit
peu un petit peu réflexe foyer sans se
marier mais qu'est ce que tu m'aies
dessus mais doris et l'huile de jojoba
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
l autre chose l'orage a beau dire à
l'état sauvage sorte sur le lot des
guides à sofia qui est dans le public
aujourd'hui bonsoir sofia elle revient
tout juste de los angeles allait mieux
sofia
mais attention j'adore ces deux là
[Musique]
yark
on m'a dit qu'on lui
sa joie
y a pas que nous qui sommes sexy sur les
réseaux sera oui aussi mais non laquelle
elle regarde qu'est ce qu'elle a appris
à les voir le bras gauche
la trad dégradé progressif elle va
dégrader progressivement séché par notre
meilleur exactement alors mais ça alors
c'était un copain à moi sans rigoler
bonjour c'est vrai il envoya voulait
faire un combat contre moi y'a pas je
veux dire vraiment combattre contre moi
je vais te massacrer pour vous changer
de voie quand on parlait une langue
étrange les amériques les chéris il est
20 heures et je voulais vous dire qu'il
faut je voulais déjà vous dire que cette
saison c'est vrai que chaque saison est
différente chaque saison on croît chaque
fois avoir connu des choses qu'on
connaîtra jamais la saison d'après et
chaque saison on connaît des choses
encore plus formidable dans tous les
sens cette année vraiment vous voulez
vraiment être peint rigolade et c'est ce
qu'on fera encore plus l'année prochaine
puisque je vous dis tu es pmp sera
vraiment un espace de divertissement à
l'année prochaine c'est vraiment un
espace de divertissement va vraiment que
rigoler et balances ton poste qui
revient bien entendu sera l'espace du
débat
je voulais remercier public qui a
toujours été là vraiment tous les gens
qui m'ont soutenue sur twitter sur un
star sur facebook tous les gens qui
m'ont remercié d'avoir et à l'antenne
avec l'équipe pendant ces périodes de
confinement c'est vous qui nous donnait
la force vraiment d'être d'avoir envie
de vous montrer ce qu on a fait tous les
jours c'est un petit peu voilà on ait
envie de vous montrer ce qu'on a envie
de faire de vous montrer des nouveaux
projets de vous proposer de nouvelles
choses
on a envie de me divertir tous les soirs
[Musique]